[Music]
there's nothing like a good
old-fashioned musical to lift our
spirits sky-high small fit will be
unlike anything we've ever seen and it's
safe to say that our expectations are
soaring through the roof watch until the
end to find out why small foots release
date got postponed new around here don't
forget to give us a big thumbs up and
subscribe to the things do this and more
amazing content we'll head your way now
let's jump into the dark secrets about
the small foot movie froggy
shown the evidence it isn't Zendaya's
first time at the rodeo by now most of
you know everything there is to know
about the gorgeous zendaya this family
channel star began her acting career
when she was just a preteen and just
like her it's been growing ever since
to say that zendaya is a busy person
would be an understatement especially
since she's been working on three
different productions in 2018 alone when
it comes to choosing her roles the
actress likes to take on fun and
challenging work knowing this
there was no way she'd be able to turn
down the role of Michi as many of you
know zendaya is as beautiful as she is
talented so in other words the girl can
sing for this reason and many more she
was given one of small foots leading
roles while many new actors face some
challenges when voice acting for the
first time this isn't India's first time
at the rodeo believe it or not this is
her fourth time in the studio
she began her voice acting career when
she was only 15 years old since then
she's lent her voice to Pixie Hollow
games super buddies and duck-duck-goose
sure zendaya might seem like the newest
celebrity in Hollywood but the girl sure
knows what she's doing
behind the music every good musical
needs a key writer but when it comes to
small foot it took a collaboration of
people to seal the deal the movies music
was composed by hate or Pereira who just
so happened to write the music for
movies like The Smurfs and Despicable Me
all in all Pereira is a shoe-in when
musicals are at hand
however he isn't behind the movies
breakout song singer Niall Horan is the
mastermind behind small foots finally
free horn released this single in the
summer of 2018 all the while knowing
that it would rock the scene when small
foot came to be if you're not familiar
with this singer it's probably because
you haven't heard his song slow hands
yet
should this be the case you should
definitely check it out want us to
predict your future
well we predict that you won't be able
to get the song finally free out of your
head for days everyone knows that the
small foot isn't real
[Music]
LeBron James is branching out into
acting by now we're all up to date with
this movie's promising soundtrack so why
not take a peek at the actors behind the
scenes many of us were shocked when it
was announced that NBA player LeBron
James would be joining small foots cast
the revelation seemed too good to be
true but alas it isn't while it isn't
the athletes first time in front of the
camera it is his first time playing
someone other than himself in other
words the superstar is used to cameos
and nothing but cameos to say that James
had a challenging time voicing his
character Guan Yi would be a lie which
leaves us asking one simple question is
there anything this legend can't do were
you shocked to find out that this star
would be joining a small foot crew if so
let us know if you prefer him in front
of the camera or on the court so much to
do so little time with so many amazing
movies coming out in 2018 it could be
hard to get excited for just one so
instead of freaking out take a breather
and take it one movie at a time small
foot will be in theaters on September
28th 2018 however it was supposed to
come out much earlier than this when the
film was first announced producer stated
that it would be coming out in the
spring of 2018
well spring has come and gone and we're
still waiting in the end it's only
normal for movies of this magnitude to
run a little late after all there's so
much to be accounted for this is
especially true when working with
big-time actors since many of them are
working on more than one project at the
same time things like collaborating in a
Stu
can become a challenge still the movie
is coming out a lot later than
previously predicted which makes us
wonder could something have gone wrong
that they're not telling us we guess
we'll uncover the truth once the movie
comes out for good a wonderful yet
familiar storyline did you notice
anything strange while watching the
trailer for small foot we sure did it's
come to our attention that small foot
isn't exactly as original as it seems to
be sure it's gonna have its own
storyline and hilarious jokes something
just doesn't seem right first off the
way this film is animated is gonna be
similar to big time movies like the
peanuts movie and Captain Underpants the
first epic movie on top of that it sort
of has a similar plot to monsters inc
and hotel transylvania don't see the
connection well allow us to elaborate
all three of these movies have one thing
in common
humans are the enemy in other words
we're sympathizing with the monsters and
rooting against the humans while we're
sure that small foot will be filled with
surprises we can't help but recognize
its plot from a mile away
regardless small foot is an animated
musical that'll rock our world in no
time the truth about humans and yetis
yeah I did no I did no I saw it doesn't
exist small foot maybe a kids movie but
it has some pretty powerful themes to it
while many of us grew up believing in
the famous Yeti we were often reassured
that no such thing existed have you seen
the small foot trailer yet if so you
probably saw a handful of small foot
characters telling me go that humans do
not exist however just because someone
tells you something isn't real doesn't
mean you should trust them blindly since
migos eyes are fully functional he
believes in what he saw and is
determined to prove it while this movie
is a work of fiction
it does have some sad truths to it one
of them being that if yetis were real
they'd be better off keeping their
distance from all human life forms by
the way the trailer ended it's pretty
easy to see that Percy is absolutely
terrified of yetis and wants nothing to
do with them whether a MIGO and Percy
form a friendship is yet to be
determined but if they do we hope that
human nature won't play a wicked
and hopefully Percy will be able to keep
the yetis existence a secret no matter
how many teeth he loses along the way
are you super excited to watch the
latest from the Warner animated group
movies if so let us know which character
you're most excited to see on the big
screen and that's it for dark secrets
about the small foot movie thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]